We’ve all got a card or handful of cards that make
us happy and somehow manage to wrangle their way
into far more decks than one would expect just
because we want to play with them more. And this
is a very normal, human impulse, an impulse that
I share. Skull Storm, Shigeki, Mask of Memory,
and the mages are cards that I always have lurking
in the back of my mind, begging me to put them
into a deck. But, should that voice be listened
to? Should these pet cards be slammed in as many
decks as possible? The answer to that is not a
clean yes or no, and depends on a couple factors.
First of all, I should define here what I mean
by pet card. This is generally thought of as
cards that players have some sort of fondness
toward, but pet cards can be pet cards for
a variety of different reasons—players might
enjoy the art or flavor, they might find the
card’s effect cool and unique, and they also
might just really enjoy what the card has to
offer for their deck. For starters, I want to
address the pet cards that are either generally
bad, or so hyper-specific that it’s
difficult to find a deck where they
truly feel at home. One good option for these
is to build a deck with the understanding that
it’s here to fulfill the most primal of pet card
desires. If it’s a card you like for aesthetics,
build a deck that fits that aesthetic. If it’s
a card you like for its effect, find cards
that go with it in some way and make that the
broader thing. The deck likely won’t be great,
but that’s fine because it’s not here to be
great. I doubt any of this is controversial,
but I figure I should express it anyway since this
category of cards often does make up a nonzero
portion of the cards that people consider their
pet cards. On the opposite end of the spectrum,
there are the pet cards that are just good, or at
least they’re flexible enough to never feel bad.
I poked around a bit in forums and saw a handful
of answers like Dawn Charm, Swan Song, and Kambal,
Consul of Allocation. And yeah, these cards are
just good, you can put them in a deck of their
colors and they will be almost guaranteed to feel
at least decent in a casual EDH game. I mentioned
Shigeki earlier, and I’d like to put that card in
this category as well—I run it in two different
ramp-heavy green decks, and having a flexible
recursion ability that’s uncounterable and at
instant is good enough that the card never feels
dead. Is that just cope on my part? Who knows!
With that, we’ve knocked out the cases of cards
that aren’t very good, and cards that are strong
and/or flexible enough to feel good in most games.
That leaves us with the stuff in the middle.
What does one do with a moderately potent
card with a somewhat specific use case? Well,
there are two options for this. Option A is you
take one or two pet cards, and build a specific
deck for them. Too often I’ve seen people keep
cards in their deck that are ill-fitting just
because they like them. And while I’m not trying
to shame anybody for playing what they like,
I think it’s useful to keep in mind that you’re
not just doing your deck a disservice—you’re also
doing that pet card a disservice. You can throw
these sorts of cards into any old deck whose color
identity they fit, but this doesn’t necessarily
mean they’ll feel satisfying. These sorts of cards
won’t reach their full potential if you’re playing
them in a deck they only tangentially connect to,
and at the worst you might gradually grow a
resentment for them if you keep drawing them
rather than a card that is more useful. Meanwhile,
the act of building a deck that a pet card fully
belongs in is the greatest act of love you can
show your favorite piece of cardboard, and it
can also be quite fun to build around a card
that you love. I’ve done this for Astral Slide,
Maze’s End, and Time Sieve, and in all three
cases it led to a deck that is a blast to play,
and which I actively enjoy the process of
tuning. Some decks built this way will be
stronger than others due to the potential power
of the card in question—the Time Sieve deck is
definitely the strongest of those last three—but
the principle still stands. Figuring out how to
best express a card, either in terms of power
level or in terms of vibe, is a lot of fun.
The other option for utilizing niche,
moderately powerful pet cards is to put
a bunch in one deck, basically to figure
out a deck that is well-equipped to handle
a number of different types of effects. The
Astral Slide and Maze’s End decks I built,
along with my Meria voltron deck, are all too
focused to throw other random pet cards into
without incurring significant losses to deck
quality, but there are other types of deck that
are much more flexible in what sorts of cards they
can accommodate. One of these is midrange decks
with simple goals and a solid core. My Radha deck
is running all sorts of fun cards that I enjoy,
and it’s able to do this because the types of
cards that the deck is looking for are 6-7 drops
with some sort of meaningful game impact, and 4
cost cards that vaguely gesture at the concept
of ramp. The deck is also built on a budget
and limited to being mid-power by its nature,
so it can accommodate a lot of cards that are
too weak for a higher power deck. My friend Hans
has a Jensen Carthalion deck that’s basically
just five color beatdown, and the cards that
make the cut for what the deck is looking for
is basically anything that lets it hit people
with angel tokens more vigorously. If you want
a pithy rule of thumb, the more generic a deck’s
general game plan is, the more niche and
varied the specific card choices can be.
In addition to generic midrange decks, there
are also specific themes that lend themselves
to running more niche cards. One of these
is proliferate, a mechanic that I built at
a low power level with a commander that I love
dearly—Skeleton ship. It contains lots of juicy
cards I like such as Overwhelming Intellect,
Mind Unbound, a couple Parallax enchantments,
Grimoire of the Dead, and several questionable
storage lands, among others. None of these cards
are irredeemably bad, but they’re weird and niche
enough that I was struggling to find a home for
them elsewhere. With the generic template of a
precon-power proliferate control deck, though,
I can pack a ton of these cards and have them
all feel appropriate and all get their chance
to shine. This can also be scaled up in power
level—for a stronger proliferate deck you could
run Atraxa, and with that there are all sorts
of options. Planeswalkers are one of the more
popular ones, but a friend of mine built Atraxa as
a ramp deck with a bunch of Myojins, which ended
up pretty entertaining. Some other themes that are
pretty flexible and often overlapping are tokens,
graveyard stuff, and synergies with a specific
card type such as artifacts or enchantments. The
key here is just that you need to figure out a
solid core to the deck—you should make sure it
has a way to get off the ground, usually
by having enough lands, ramp, and draw,
and then you can start to sprinkle in your spicier
stuff and add support where needed for different
types of cards. It’s also good to make sure that
you don’t forget to run interaction—protection
for vulnerable elements of the deck and removal to
make sure that opponents don’t run away with the
game are important aspects in most decks, and
they’re too often forgotten in the pursuit of
a fun vision. It may be tempting to disregard
these, but if you’re making a funny deck, how
well-rounded it is may determine whether it ends
up being a deck you keep wanting to play with,
or whether it ends up getting set aside as
that gimmick deck that was fun for a while.
To reiterate a couple key points, pet cards are
a fundamental part of the social fabric in just
about any collectible card game that exists,
and it’s obviously silly to suggestthat adding
them to decks is flatly wrong. At the same time,
exercising a little bit of discretion in where
these cards are played can lead to them being more
enjoyable. For those decent but somewhat niche pet
cards out there, there are two options for fitting
them into decks: building a deck around a single
card, or building a deck that’s general enough
to fit a number of these specific cards in them.
A deck that’s already focused and gunning
to complete a specific task probably
isn’t a great spot for pet cards that are only
tangentially related to what the deck is doing,
but a more general deck can be a great place to
add in some funkier choices. As a final note,
the fact that some cards don’t go well in some
decks is also why I’m such a big proponent of
budget deckbuilding. I could throw $500 at a
fancy deck, but for that same amount I could
make a half dozen decks at a lower budget point
that can all serve the interests of different
gameplay styles and different cards I love.
When I’m building decks on a higher budget,
I need to think harder about how well a deck will
work and how much I’ll actually enjoy it in the
long term. But if I’m throwing together a $50 list
based on a card I really like or a funny premise,
I can just order that sucker with no
second thoughts, knowing that if I
get a half dozen fun games out of it I’ll
be happy. And to me, that’s pretty cool.
Thanks for watching! If you’ve got
some pet cards you really like,
you can let me know in the comments. Both because
I like hearing about fun cards people like,
and also because it serves my algorithmic
overlords. That’s a win-win if I ever heard one!